The Jedi Order, Rebels tie-ins, and an ominously
familiar Sith.
The first trailer for "Obi-Wan Kenobi" is
here.
Did you catch these little details?
If you know why Obi-Wan is on Tatooine, you
might've expected this detail, but it is nonetheless
cool to see: in the teaser, we get a glimpse
of Obi-Wan observing Uncle Owen and Aunt Beru
from some high ground, and sure enough, the
Jedi's binoculars settle on what appears to
be a young Luke Skywalker pretending to pod-race.
As Star Wars fans know very well, Obi-Wan's
task is to protect him at all cost, and this
appearance of Luke certainly gives us a lot
of information as to how many years have passed
since the events of "Revenge of the Sith."
Based on what we can see, Luke seems to be
about 10 years old.
This means that the events of "Obi-Wan Kenobi"
will likely be picking up not too long after
"Revenge of the Sith."
It will be interesting to see how Obi-Wan
manages his duty of protecting Luke while
remaining out of sight.
Either way, "Obi-Wan Kenobi" promises to bring
greater insight into the young Luke's life
on Tatooine, even if Luke himself only features
briefly.
In the new teaser trailer, perhaps one of
the first things that strikes fans of "Star
Wars" is the ominous and immediately recognizable
soundtrack.
This is, of course, the John Williams masterpiece
from "Star Wars: The Phantom Menace," called
"Duel of the Fates."
"Duel of the Fates" was previously used during
the epic confrontation between Obi-Wan, Qui-Gon
Jinn, and Darth Maul in the first movie of
the prequel trilogy.
Its usage in the "Obi-Wan" trailer pays tribute
to this earlier struggle, but at this point,
it seems that the point is to more squarely
focus on the past and future of Obi-Wan as
he struggles to find his fate in a galaxy
that seeks his death.
It seems like the "Obi-Wan Kenobi" series
is gunning for more than your everyday tie-ins
to the films, because the new trailer also
shows off several of the infamous Inquisitors.
The Inquisitors, for those who missed out
on the TV series "Star Wars Rebels," are a
group of force-sensitives enlisted by the
Empire to hunt down the remaining Jedi.
Personally trained by Darth Vader, and often
former Jedi themselves, the Inquisitors play
a large part in further eradicating the Jedi
in the years following Order 66.
Throughout the trailer, we are shown three
different Inquisitors, two of which have appeared
in previous "Star Wars" stories.
The first of these is the Grand Inquisitor,
an ex-Jedi Pau'an with white skin and distinctive
face markings.
He plays an important role as a primary villain
throughout much of "Rebels," as well as in
several comics.
The other known Inquisitor is the Fifth Brother,
who was also a common sight in "Rebels" as
a minor villain.
The only Inquisitor we don't know much about
is Reva, played by Moses Ingram, who we see
getting involved in a number of tense confrontations
throughout the trailer.
Based on this, it's clear that the Inquisitors
are set to play a major role as antagonists
throughout the series, potentially crossing
sabers with Obi-Wan ... though, given that
Obi-Wan manages to make it to "A New Hope"
alive, that may not go half as well as they
think.
The universe of "Star Wars" is filled with
strange and amazing animals, and some humanoids
that straddle the line between person and
animal – looking at you, Chewie.
"Luke?
Luke's crazy!"
Obi-Wan himself is no stranger to hanging
out with a menagerie of space beasts, having
ridden everything from varactyls to aiwha
over the years.
In the "Obi-Wan" trailer, the character is
shown riding something that appears to be
a camel.
This might strike the casual "Star Wars" fan
off-guard — after all, there's no way a
Star Wars show would put a camel on Tatooine.
"No camels."
Han Solo's right: it isn't a camel.
It's actually a four-legged herbivore known
as an "eopie."
Originally from Tatooine, their adaptations
to the harsh environment make them very useful
for carrying luggage or people across the
desert ... you know, just like the camels
in our world.
The nostalgia is strong with this one.
At one point during the new "Obi-Wan" trailer,
fans are greeted by the return appearance
of actor Joel Edgerton's Uncle Owen character,
who many "Star Wars" fans will remember served
as Anakin Skywalker's step-brother in "Episode
II – Attack of the Clones" and Luke Skywalker's
guardian on Tatooine at the end of "Revenge
of the Sith."
Not surprisingly, fans are psyched.
In the "Obi-Wan" trailer, the show's big new
bad — Reva the Inquisitor — comes face-to-face
with Edgerton's Owen after arriving on Tatooine
with her evil Empire cronies.
Actor Bonnie Piesse, who played Uncle Owen's
girlfriend in Episodes II and III, is also
set to appear as her Aunt Beru character.
As fans know, the two characters are fated
to be tragically killed off in "A New Hope"
by Imperial Stormtroopers, but this will mark
the first time we truly see what their life
while raising the future Jedi hero was like.
While the "Obi-Wan Kenobi" teaser trailer
was packed to the brim with references and
epic glimpses of things to come, there's one
little moment that appears so briefly that
only die-hard fans would notice it on the
first watch.
At one point, an unknown hand touches what
appears to be a symbol carved into a wall,
which appears to be the official Jedi Order
crest: a lightsaber with elaborate wings on
either side.
It's crudely carved, but it’s an important
symbol for the Jedi Order, serving as an official
insignia for them for thousands of years before
their eventual fall.
It being carved into the wall like graffiti
is an indicator, perhaps, that hope for the
return of the Jedi remains strong.
That said, because this moment is so brief,
there's no definitive evidence that this is
the crest of the Jedi Order, and it could
be something else entirely.
While Darth Vader doesn't physically appear
in the "Obi Wan Kenobi" limited series teaser
trailer, his presence looms large.
And fans who listen carefully can hear Vader's
iconic breathing at the very end of the teaser
trailer.
Hayden Christensen, who played Anakin Skywalker
in "Attack of the Clones" and "Revenge of
the Sith," was confirmed to co-star as Darth
Vader in the upcoming series back in 2020.
Lucasfilm president Kathleen Kennedy promised
Christensen's return to "Star Wars" would
result in "the rematch of the century" between
Vader and Kenobi.
Given the heavy presence within the trailer
of the Empire's Inquisitors, it's probably
safe to say Vader will oversee their efforts
to find Kenobi.
In October 2021, The Hollywood Reporter also
reported that the now 40-year-old actor will
also reprise his role as Darth Vader in the
upcoming series "Ahsoka," alongside Rosario
Dawson.
Ahsoka Tano and Anakin Skywalker grew close
as Jedi padawan and master through "Star Wars:
The Clone Wars," making the upcoming series
a second long-awaited reunion between fan
favorites.
As for what role Vader plays in the future
of Obi-Wan Kenobi, that still remains to be
seen.
Well, sort of.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.